bonsoir et bienvenue pour une nouvelle
édition de municipale 2014 sur TVfil 78
je recevrai dans un instant Marc Robert
candidat de l'UMP à Rambouillet il aura
la lourde tâche de faire oublier Gérard
Larcher qui a souhaité ne pas se
représenter l' donc dessigné comme son
successeur Didier ficher conseiller
municipal d'opposition à coignère
viendra lui aussi s'exprimer il est pour
la première fois le candidat tête de
liste socialiste sur cette ville et nous
évoquerons également les candidatures
qui se multiplient à gauche du Parti
socialiste aussi bien à Montini le
Bretonneux qu'à saint-sirlécole le
premier invité c'est donc Marc Robert
bonsoir l'homme désigné pour succéder à
Gérard Larché en mars prochain Gérard
Larché qui après une trentaine d'années
à la tête de rbouillet ne va pas se
représenter et cette question êtes-vous
inquiet est-ce que sur le terrain la
population se se se solidarise derrière
votre candidature je crois plutôt oui
après je dirais la la partie événement
qui a été l'annon par Gérard lché de sa
décision de ne pas se représenter 31 ans
de mandat dans laun 31 ans de mandat
effectivement c'est un c'est un
événement pour les rambolitains qui ont
été habitué il est vrai à avoir des
maires dans la durabilité puisque
préalablement à lui Jacqueline topatn
avait été ma pendant 36 ans oui oui
c'est un événement que les rambolitains
ont accueilli avec beaucoup d'étonnement
je pense pour certains et puis je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont compris la
décision de gerérard Larché qui est une
décision importante que je respecte que
nous nous respectons je crois dans dans
dans la majoritaire enou Gérard Larcher
qui reste très actif he pour cette
campagne puisqu'il vous a ouvert sa
permanence il me semble absolument j'ai
rencontré bolitain qui voudrait échanger
vous repartez pour ce prochain mandat
pour cette candidature avec une grande
partie de la liste actuelle du conseil
municipal sortant avec une partie la
liste sera tout de même renouvelée avec
je dirais effectivement vous avez raison
des des des des élus de d'une équipe qui
sera constituée d'élus qui ont déjà de
l'expérience qui ont déjà prouvé de par
leur travail et leur efficacité qu'ils
était indispensable en tout cas pour moi
et effectivement composé aussi de de
nouveaux élus pour certains plus jeunes
en âge mais également bien sûr en en
maturité politique mais qui seront là
aussi pour équilibrer la liste je suis
très très comment diraisje impatient de
la délivrer au rambolittin dans quelques
semaines j'aimerais vous montrer tout de
même une photo une photo de votre
adversaire socialiste Jean-Luc
trottignon avec lui sur cette photo
Jean-Pierre blachland de centre droit
ancien conseiller régional ancien
conseiller municipal délégé de Gérard
Larcher jusqu'en 2008 il a donc décidé
de rejoindre la liste d'opposition
socialiste cette fois-ci quelle est
votre réactionou une réaction euh
d'étonnement parce qu'effectivement
Jean-Pierre blancheland que je connais
particulièrement bien pour avoir été
avec lui é Luu il y a quelques années
euh est un garçon que par ailleurs
j'apprécie en tant l'homme est un un
garçon que j'apprécie tout à fait
maintenant politiquement ben sil fait un
choix qui est qui peut-être étonnant
compte tenu de lui est très critique
hein sur le le bilan du du mer sortant
sur é sortante il parle d'absence de
transparence de délis trop long pour la
mise en place de certains projets et il
juge certaines délégations d'élu fictiv
je pense que Monsieur l'archer pourrait
lui répondre quant à ces ces questions
je pense que c'est pas à moi de le faire
mais je je je suis convaincu qu'il a
tort de penser cela très critique
également jeanluc trottignon qui est
votre adversaire socialiste qui siège
déjà au conseil municipal en tant que
conseiller de d'opposition socialiste il
a notamment attaqué en justice le maire
pour des indemnités de trop perçu il a
aussi critiqué les emprunts toxiques de
la commune ces emprunts à taux variable
quel regard vous portez non pas sur sur
ces différentes déclarations mais en
tout cas sur ces emprunts parce que il
pèse aussi ça peser sur les comptes de
la ville de Rambouillet oui oui tout à
fait comme dans beaucoup de communes et
là je dirais que la le positionnement
politique des des communes en question
n'a rien à voir je crois
qu'effectivement un certain nombre de
collectivités à un moment sont allé vers
ce type d'emprunt Distr ça peut
handicaper l'avenir euh pas rambouiller
puisque monsieur Larcher et son équipe
aujourd'hui fait le le quasi nécessaire
pour que justement ce poids des empruns
structurées dans dans les finances de la
ville soit des plus réduit quel regard
vous portez sur le bilan sur l'équipe
sortante est-ce que vous assumez vous ce
bilan lorsque vous vous présentez
lorsque vous faites campagne moi
j'assume ce bilan oui tout à même si
vous n'étiez pas je le rappelle tout à
fait mais je l'assume parce que pendant
19 ans et avant 2008 puisque j'ai cessé
ces fonctions d'élu en 2008 j'ai
effectivement fait partie de cette
équipe pendant 19 ans avec au côté de
Gérard Larcher et d'autres élus y
compris Jean-Pierre blancheland
d'ailleurs et et je l'assume
complètement parce que je pense que
rambouillé a été transformé rambouillé
s'est donné une identité une qualité de
vie que nous devons aujourd'hui à à
l'arché et ses équipes depuis qure ou et
5 mandat alors pour bien vous
représenter hein pour les
téléspectateurs qui ne vous connaissent
pas encore vous avez 54 ans vous êtes né
à rambbouillet vous connaissez bien
cette ville vous y avez fait également
du sport pour les amateurs de basket qui
qui s'en souviendront vous y avez joué
là-bas pendant de nombreuses années
pourquoi en 2008 vous avez décidé de
quitter le conseil municipal parce que
de 1989 vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure jusqu'en 2008 vous siégez au
conseil municipal au côté de Gérard
Larcher oui c'était une décision qui
était liée au-delà du fait que 19 années
c'est quand même
un temps relativement long pour lorsquon
s'emploie et qu'on se donne pour les les
citoyens et j'avais un projet
professionnel surtout qui qui métait
important à gérer c'est la raison
essentielle pour laquelle en 2008 j'ai
là aujourd'hui Gérard Larcher son équipe
sont venus vous chercher on va pas dire
ça comme ça en tout cas j'ai eu pendant
de 2008 à aujourd'hui toujours et encore
des contacts avec Gérard Larcher à
travers d'autres d'autres fonctions
notamment un club de de réflexion
politique que nous avons mené tous les
deux pendant 8 ans et je je mon
appartenance ma je dirais ma ma le fait
que j'ai toujours vécu à rambouiller et
que j'aime cette ville que j ai
travaillé m'a engagé effectivement il y
a quelques mois à pouvoir envisager de
de pouvoir se succéder à Gérard Larchet
avec toute je dirait je sais que c'est
un challenge qui est pas qui est pas
évident mais en tout cas j'ai la
conviction et surtout la volonté d' d'y
aboutir parce que j'adore cette ville
j'aime cette viille et vous voulez
passer dès le premier tour c'est ce que
vous disiez à nos conf parisien il y a
pas très longs oui oui oui tout à fait
ça alors j'ai entendu que c'était un
manque d'humilité pardon si c'est un
manque d'humilité mais effectivement je
me donne des objectifs je suis toujours
des objectifs dans la vie donc celui-ci
effectivement fait partie de mes
objectifs éventuellement il y aura une
liste Front Nationale sur la commune
est-ce que ça peut est-ce que ça peut
changer les choses est-ce que ça peut
changer le scrutin modifier un petit peu
les rapports de force au sein de la
ville ah ben écoutez oui par définition
une liste présente va
effectivement collecter des des des
votes donc est-ce est-ce que c'est une
liste que vous surveillez pour être très
clair est-ce que vous regardez la FA je
la surveille pas plus pas moins que les
autres listes que Cell des autres
candidats qui sont déclarés notamment
celle des des socialistes on parlait
tout à l'heure de la candidature de de
Jean-Luc trottignon quelles sont vos
priorités pour cette campagne comment
vous abordez la suite lorsqu'on
préparait cet entretien vous vous me
disiez que ce serait plutôt un mandat
économe faire attentionou oui oui alors
là c'est une priorité vous l'avez je
vous l'ai dit effectivement je je je le
redis les les contraintes budgétaires
qui vont s'imposer aux communes et à
rembouiller bien évidemment sont telles
que ce mandat sera un mandat d'économie
sera un mandat d'attention particulière
sur le budget la stabilité fiscale est
une une un objectif pour mon équipe
demain à travers la stabilité fiscale il
faudra faire des choix il faudra être
raisonnable et en tout cas ça sera mon
je dirais ma vision de ce mandat et en
tout cas mon attention au quotidien pour
le mandat à venir oui oui tout à ça veut
dire qu'il ne faut pas avoir d'ambition
pour la ville si si il faut avoir des
ambitions il surtout avoir des priorités
faire des ambitions faêre imaginatif je
crois qu'on va vers une période c'est
même pas je crois je suis certain où les
dans les collectivités il va falloir
peut-être avoir une vision différente
des projets et et je le dis toujours et
encore à mes futurs colestiers il faudra
être très imaginatif mais aussi
l'ambition de pouvoir réaliser des
belles choses pour remouiller bien sûr
alors quelles sont vos priorités
justement en terme d'urbanisme par
exemple est-ce qu'il y a encore des
choses à revoir en terme de logement en
terme d'éducation aussi parce qu'il y a
un dossier qui se pose à tous les merc
la question de la réforme des rythmes
scolaires comment vous abordez ces
questions-là alors sur sur l'urbanisme
on a rembouillé un outil fondamental qui
est le PLU qui est aujourd'hui en place
et qui donne nous donne une direction
sur les prochaines et les nombreuses
années à venir qui nous rassurent euh ça
nécessitera pour nous d'avoir une vision
de la croissance en terme de population
qui sera modérée euh aujourd'hui
j'annonce effectivement clairement que
cette croissance ne pourra être au-delà
de 0,75 % par an euh ça c'est je dirais
l'élément fondamental pour éviter que
Rambouillet perde sa qualité de vie et
son identité je suis très attaché comme
rambolitin mais je sais que les
rambolitains y sont attachés
effectivement après effectivement la
famille est un élément un axe important
pour nous euh c'est c'est un socle c'est
le socle de la société donc nous
renforcerons ce que nous appliquons
depuis des années à rambouiller sur la
présence de la famille mais je dirais
c'est l'axe intergénérationnel hein de
des tout petits jusque à nos nos seniors
nous avons la responsabilité de nous
occuper de de tout ce petit monde
j'allais dire et de faire évoluer aussi
la ville dans ce sens après estce que
vous parlez des familles juste parce que
le temps passe vite juste sur la
question de l'éducation alors sur les
les temps scolaires notamment c'est
votre question ben écoutez Rambouillet a
fait comme beaucoup de communes et je
crois la totalité de la com commune
plein foreline à laquelle appartient
rambouillé a dit qu'elle bien évidemment
que la rentrée 2013 ne serait pas dans
le cadre de la de la de la réforme nous
attendons 2014 en espérant je vous je
vous l'accorde que cette réforme soit
totalement revue si possible nous nous
nous y préparons malgré tout parce
qu'effectivement si en septembre il faut
être prêt nous serons prêts mais je peux
vous je fais partie de ceux qui ne
comprennent pas aujourd'hui l'insistance
du gouvernement sur cette réforme merci
Marc Robert d'être venu sur ce plateau
candidat UMP à Rambouillet pour évoquer
ok ce début de campagne Merci à VOUS
municipal 2014 se poursuit dans quelques
minutes c'est Didier Fiser qui sera à
votre place un candidat socialiste à
coanière François de Maier mer sortant à
versaill à nouveau candidat il a reçu
cette année le soutien de l'UMP dès le
premier tour ce n'était pas le cas en
2008 Bertrand dev lui avait été préféré
pour succéder à Étienne pin mais il
n'avait pas réussi à convaincre les
électeurs et la droite avait revu ses
plans il se dit aujourd'hui que de
vieilles rivalités pourraient rurgir des
non circules mais la présidente de l'UMP
veut couper court aux rumeurs la
réaction de Valérie pcrè au micro de
yolen Torz François de maierre a
l'investiture de
l'UMP c'est un ami très très proche et
là aussi ce qu'il fait pour Versailles
est absolument magnifique en terme de
rénovation urbaine et en terme de
transformation de la
ville voilà pour cette réaction de
Valérie pcrè le Parti socialiste peine à
rassembler l'ensemble de la gauche ch
Montini le Bretonneux la plupart des
formations qui composent le Front de
gauche ont décidé de soutenir la
candidature du conseiller municipal
d'opposition actuelle pierre desjan ce
dernier s'explique sur son choix nous
l'avons
rencontré nous sommes ferm et et
déterminés est-ce que nous aurons
effectivement le temps de construire une
liste complète je n'en sais rien en fait
nous cherchion à rassembler tous ceux
qui lutteent pour changer la société
alors il y a tout un tas de formes de
lutte ça peut être politique ça peut
être syndicale ça peut être ass iniatif
donc l'essentiel c'est d'avoir une vue
politique commune il ne faut pas faire
de distinction entre locale et nationale
la République française est une et
indivisible et il y a des liens directs
entre ce qui se passe au niveau national
et ce qui se passe au niveau local
premier exemple pour la les
collectivités
territoriales le gouvernement a décidé
qu'il y aurait une baisse l'année
prochaine de 1 milliard et demi d'euros
dans les dotations de l'État au communes
et et au région et donc automatiquement
ça a un impact sur les citoyens ou bien
on supprime des services ou bien on
augmente les impôts aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui se passe sur montigi par
exemple on a une une politique qui est
clairement menée en faveur des plus
aisés et il y a un enchirissement qui se
fait terrible promenez-vous dans les
rues regardez le nombre d'appartements
qui sont en vente ça veut dire que même
les gens qui ont eu la capacité de de de
s'acheter un appartement aujourd'hui ne
pas suivre et tout ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui construit regardez avec
l'ensemble vélopolce regardez avec bon
le projet karaté de comment on dit un
outlet chez les gamb bienens enfin donc
de magasin de luxe tout ça ça fait
effectivement qu'on amène le luxe et qu'
donc on renchirit la ville on renchirit
le foncier et ceeter donc tout ça il
faut l'arrêter nous on propose une
politique de gauche clairement et nous
sommes déterminés à la suivre regardez
si vous n'avez pas confiance parce queil
y a raison de aucune raison de faire
confiance à ma bonne tête regardez
aujourd'hui ce que font les députés et
les sénataures du Front de Gauche
regardez les projets de loi qu'il
soumettent et bien vous verrez que nous
sommes clairs et ferme dans nos position
je crois il faut que les citoyens se
rendent compte qu'il n'y a pas de
démocratie possible sans une application
des citoyens donc je dirais à tous
les faites de la politique il n'y a que
cela qui sauvera la politique et il y a
pas de démocratie qui puiss vivre en
dehors de l'implication citoyenne une
nouvelle liste à gauche de la gauche
qu'en pense le candidat socialiste de
Montini le bretonne Vivien gaz que nous
lui avons posé la question lors de l'une
de ses réunions publiques cette semaine
moi j'aurais à titre personnel préféré
que qu' ait une seule une seule
dynamique une seule une seule logique de
d'opposition euh au au maire sortant euh
bon ce ce serait peut-être ça aurait pu
être préférable maintenant on n'est pas
encore au au bout il y a peut-être
encore des discussions à avoir il y a un
rapport de force qui va aussi se
construire au soir du premier tour et
peut-être que ça peut changer les choses
entre les deux tours moi pour l'instant
je ne préjuge absolument de rien il y a
6 mois tout le monde nous disait que
Europe Écologie les vers était dans une
liste Face à Nous contre nous
aujourd'hui vous allez voir que on
arrive à travailler ensemble et en bonne
intelligence voilà dans le respect des
différents des différents partenaires
vous laissz la porte ouverte oh bah de
mon point de vue oui la porte est
totalement ouverte ouais bien sûr et
pour le compte-rendu de ce début de
campagne de Vivien Gasque rendez-vous
dans le 78 lactu le journal de la
rédaction est sur notre site Internet à
partir de mercredi soir 11 décembre
cette division de la gauche se
retrouvait également à saincir l'école
c'est par un communiqué que le Front de
Gauche a fait savoir qu'elle souhaite
battre la gauche en faisant je cite des
choix clairement à gauche rencontre
public de lancement de cette nouvelle
liste sur la ville le 17 décembre à
l'école Romain Rolland à 20h30 et puis
pendant ce temps toujours à saincè
l'école l'ancienne adjointe au maire
Bernard Debin qui a donc choisi
d'affronter celui avec lequel elle a
siégé durant ce mandat qui sach chève
poursuit sa campagne Gaetane des jardins
tiendra un café rencontre le samedi 14
décembre sur le thème du sport cette
fois-ci ce sera à 17h avenu pierre Cury
elle annonce également vouloir créer en
cas de victoire au scrutin un nouveau
gymnase dans cette future ZAC renard qui
fait beaucoup parler les différents
candidat je reçois donc à présent Didier
ficher bonsoir bonsoir euh vous êtes le
candidat du PS à coignère pour la
première fois tête de liste sur cette
ville de coign vous numéro 2 en en 2008
précédent scrutin pourquoi cette année
porter cette candidature socialiste
parce qu'il me semble que c'est
important et en effet de porter cette
candidature à coignère aujourd'hui hein
après 30 ans de mandat pratiquement 30
ans pour le maire sortant je crois qu'il
est nécessaire aujourd'hui d'avoir une
forme de respiration démocratique pour
coignère H plus de 60 % en 2008 c'est le
score de des élections d'enry paayux au
précédent scrutin avec en plus une
participation au scrutin qui était plus
élevée à l'époque que dans le reste du
département
pouro ça va changer cette année ça va
changer parce que qu'est-ce qui a changé
dans cette ville pour vous permettre
d'espérer une victoire en mar ce qui a
changé ce qu'il faut voir en effet c'est
que aux dernières élections les
dernières élections la ville a
régulièrement voté à gauche je pense
qu'on a fait avec notre équipe coignè
pour tous je dirais un bon mandat un
mandat dans l'opposition mais un mandat
en quelque sorte très productif pour
l'ensemble des coignériens même avec un
mauvais vent au National même si le
contexte nation pour le Parti socialiste
est difficile vous pouvez encore espérer
oui le contexte national est peut-être
difficile mais nous sommes dans une
petite ville 4500 habitants je pense que
les thématiques les préoccupations de la
population sont des préoccupations
beaucoup plus quotidiennes et nous
entendons répondre en fait au quotidien
des coignierien avec mon équipe alors
pour être très clair justement vous
parlez de cette équipe sur cette affiche
de de campagne que vous avez publié
récemment on ne voit pas le logo du
Parti socialiste pour l'instant c'est ma
déclaration de candidature c'est ma
déclaration de
candid on ne voit pas le logo du Parti
social parce que mon équipe n'est pas
composée de socialistes uniquement loin
de là on a quatre personnes qui sont au
Parti socialiste sinon c'est une équipe
beaucoup plus large qui englobe qui va
englober des personnalités à l'heure
actuelle de coignère donc nous n'aurons
pas nous n'aurons pas le logo sur
laffiche du Parti socialiste quels sont
les les les les partis pardon qui vous
soutiennent pour cette campagne estce
vous avez réussi à fédérer les partis on
a on a une forme de fédération citoyenne
en définitive sur notre liste on n'est
pas soutenu par un parti particulier on
est une liste citoyenne pour l'essentiel
votre priorité pour cette ville l'une de
ces priorités c'est notamment préserver
son caractère rural c'est ce que vous
dites he pourtant c'est pas ce qui saute
aux yeux lorsqu'on connaitt moin bien
coignère parce que on utilise cette
national
10it et on ne voit pas que coignère
c'est aussi un village que coignère il y
a un esprit village qu'il nous faut
aujourd'hui conserver il faut alors ça
veut dire qu'il faut mixer les deux
justement ce côté commerce ce côté sû
bien sûr les commerces sont importants
parce qu'ils apportent la richesse à not
comm aujourd'hui lesagriens le savent
bien le taux d'imposition est
relativement bas il est bas parce que
justement nous avons nousons nous avons
nos commerces et donc il faut préserver
en effet nos zones d'activité il faudra
peut-être les réorganiser il faudra
peut-être diversifier l'emploi parce
qu'il y a un véritable sujet là sur
l'emploi àinière aujourd'hui puisque
près de 12 % de la population active est
au chômage donc ça sera une des
priorités de notre campagne le commerce
qui s'est encore développé pendant la
cette cette mandature de d'Henri pa il y
a eu le centre commercial des portes de
chevus qui a vu le jour notamment quel
regard vous portez sur ce développement
économique sur ces créations de commerce
non mais le regard qu'on porte et
j'allais dire pragmatique à partir du
moment où ce commerce enrichit notre
ville et permet en fait d'avoir une
politique sociale relativement développé
et bien c'est un bienfait pour notre
commun pour lesqu c'est
plusile bien sûr on ne va pas refuser en
effet l'installation je dirais
d'entreprise sur coignère bien au
contraire alors il y a en effet des
zones surcoignères où c'est beaucoup
plus difficile bien là il va falloir
qu'on y travaille bien sûr comment vous
voyez le la possibilité de redynamiser
toute cette zone autour de de la gare
bon je pense que autour de la gare il
faudra qu'on qu'on aille vers un
écoquartier beaucoup plus de façon
justement à redynamiser cette gare et
ensuite il faudra qu'on développe les
transports parce que ça c'est un sujet
primordial aujourd'hui à coinière quand
on pense qu'à l'heure actuelle il n'y a
pas une ligne d'autobus qui va jusqu'à
la gare de coignère donc il va falloir
repenser en fait tout un Plan de
Déplacement Urbain sur coignière et
c'est à cela qu'on va s'atteler bien
entendu avec mon équipe alors repensez
ce plan et pourquoi pas discuter avec la
communauté d'agglomération de sa- qutin
parce que vous parliez de liaison
justement jusqu'à coignère ce serait il
y aura il y aura bien entendu des des
discussions avec la communé vous pose
cette question parce que communauté de
Saint-Quentin reind V c'est la décision
vous savez c'est la décision du préfet
de rejoindre la la CCE ce qui n'empêche
alors juste pour rappeler hein c'est la
communauté de commune des étanss et
effectivement ce regroupement des
différentes communes ça concerne toutes
les communes de France qui ne font pas
partie encore d'agglomération au 1er
janvier elles devront toutes en faire
partie et donc il y a un choix qui a été
fait pour la ville de coière c'est la
communauté de commune des étant alors
que la communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin avait un temps été
pressenti d'ailleurs par le passé
coignère en faisait partie à la création
il y a bien longtemps de cette ville
nouvelle bien sûr c'est positif de
rejoindre la communauté de commune des é
je dirais que c'est je dirais que c'est
pas négatif c'est c'est pas c'est c'est
c'est à mon avis pour l'instant
aujourd'hui la moins mauvaise des
solutions dans le contexte quanirien
actuel euh en fait il y aura bien
entendu je dirais débat aussi avec la
communauté d'agglomération quand on
parle transport évidemment évidemment
avec la casquille il faudra qu'on
négocie mais il faudra qu'on négocie
aussi avec le STIF hein le syndicat des
transports d'île-de-fance parce que
c'est à partir de cette négociation avec
le STIF qu'on pourra obtenir à mon avis
le prolongement de la ligne jusqu'à
jusqu'à la gare et la desserte aussi des
quartiers excentrés de poignère ça c'est
une priorité ça sera une des priorités
de mon mandat vous parliez du du stitif
vous êtes conseiller régional
Île-deFrance régional d'île-de-fance
tout à fait et effectivement je peux
peut-être avoir un petit poids de ce
côté-là en restant conseiller régional
d'île-de-fance si vous êtes élu en mars
vous conservez les deux mandats comment
vous conservez les de mandats mars pour
l'instant oui en mars oui je conserverai
les deux mandats ensuite je me poserai
la question bien entendu je me poserai
la question en 2015 est-ce que je
conserve mon mandat de conseiller
régional ou est-ce que finalement je je
démissionne ou je ne me représente pas
ça sera ça sera à débattre à ce
moment-là bien entendu pour me consacrer
uniquement à la ville de coignère on a
survolé les différents points de votre
programme qui est encore en cours
d'élaboration comment ça va se
concentrer dans les prochaines semaines
prochains mois à quel moment quel sera
votre timing pour la liste quelles
seront les réunions la liste est prête
hein vous savez euh çait ça fait 6 ans
que nous sommes en campagne oui oui la
liste est prête elle est complète nous
avons fait les photos les photos de
groupe la photo de liste et je pense que
le 10 nous aurons notre premier réunion
publique et là je ferai une présentation
officielle de la liste et un quatre page
sera adressé à l'ensemble le des
coignerien avec cette liste le 10
janvier et ensuite à la fin du mois de
janvier l'ensemble des coigneriens
auront aussi le projet projet que nous
préparons à l'heure actuelle par des
réunions aussi hein là dans tout à
l'heure dans dans 30 minutes je suis en
réunion d'appartement donc je rencontre
au quotidien dans la proximité là les
coignnerriens la priorité s'il devait y
avoir une seule priorité pour le mandat
si vous étiez élu ce serait quoi bah la
priorité à l'heure actuelle j'avais dit
les transports hein l'emploi les
transports bien entendu mais aussi il
faut pas l'oublier on a parlé tout à
l'heure des commerces les commerces de
proximité le cœur aujourd'hui de
coinière et de plus en plus privé de
commerce de proximité on a encore une
boulangerie une petite supérette un
coiffeur mais c'est aujourd'hui très
fragile tout cela comment une
municipalité peut influer pour faire
rester ses commerces parce que ça touche
toutes villes P oui ça touche toutes les
villes mais on voit bien que dans un
certain nombre de villes en France les
municipalités mettent en place des plans
de maintien et de défense du commerce de
proximité qui peut aller par exemple
jusqu'au rachat de locaux et mise en
gérence ensuite pour entretenir un
commerce de proximité c'est presque un
service public à ce niveau-là nombre de
communes l'ont fait aujourd'hui en
France et ça marche pas si mal merci
Didier fichard d'être venu sur ce
plateau je rappelle que vous êtes
candidat à la mairie de coignère en tant
que tête de liste Parti socialiste mais
vous nous l'avez dit la liste est plus
large que ça il y a quatre socialistes
sur votre sur votre liste puisque nous
étions à coignère sachez aussi que si
vous souhaitez visiter cette nouvelle
mairie elle ouvrira ses portes pour des
visites guidées 18 décembre de 15h à 19h
journée portes ouvertes pour mieux
comprendre le fonctionnement des
services voilà la mairie de coiniière
qui avait fait puve récemment c'est la
fin de ce numéro de municipal 2014
prochain numéro ce sera en janvier le 7
janvier et ensuite ce sera chaque
semaine jusqu'au scrutin 2 mars fin mars
et puis la rédaction vous proposera
aussi à partir de février des débats sur
une quinzaine de communes clés du
département afin de vous aider à faire
votre choix avant de voter rendez-vous
en janvier et puis bien sûr d'ici là
chaque soir pour le journal de la
rédaction chaque soir du lundi au
vendredi à 18h bonne
soirée